[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend hinein an einem
tag an dem man sich die augen reibt ob
der deutschen corona politik nichts
neues werden sie vielleicht sagen und in
der tat es hat ja einiges an chaos
gegeben in den vergangenen zwei jahren
und exakt da schließt der
bundesgesundheitsminister jetzt an
vorgestern hatte er nach beratungen mit
seinen kolleginnen und kollegen in den
bundesländern verkündet wer infiziert
ist muss ab erster mai nicht mehr zu
hause bleiben die isolation gelte dann
nur noch freiwillig das prinzip
eigenverantwortung
gestern nimmt er alles wieder zurück in
der talkshow von markus lanz und per
tweet um 2 uhr 37 christiane hübscher
über das hin und her dass karl
lauterbach
der druck ist zu groß geworden am mittag
zieht karl lauterbach seine umstrittene
entscheidung zur nicht isolation von
corona infizierten auch offiziell zurück
das war ein fehler den ich auch
persönlich verantwortlich bin das war
eine fehleinschätzung den eigentlichen
rückzieher aber macht der minister schon
am späten abend ausgerechnet in einer
talkshow ich glaube dass das zwar den
gesundheitsämtern helfen würde das der
symbolische schaden aber ist nicht mehr
so gefährlich so verheerend ist dass man
diese isolations ordnung so nicht machen
kann also diesen punkt hin werde ich
wieder einkassieren und schickt dann
mitten in der nacht noch einen social
media suite hinterher in dem er schreibt
hier habe ich einen fehler gemacht im
gesundheitsausschuss lässt sich
lauterbach am morgen nicht blicken
andere müssen sich dort für ihn erklären
insofern bitte ich auch da im sinne der
kolleginnen kollegen aus der koalition
um entschuldigung das ist kein gutes
kommunizieren ein rücktritt habe er
nicht gedacht so der minister doch die
seltsame fehlerkultur des karl
lauterbach provoziert sofort wieder
kritik aus den ländern sogar der eigenen
partei wenn man das einfach per ordre de
mufti and rock show verkündet anlass das
gab die länder im regen stehen und
verunsichert die bevölkerung und das ist
schon eine kommunikative fehlleistung
die menschen erwarten auch in dieser
phase der pandemie
klarheit und verlässlichkeit und dann
ist natürlich nicht gut wenn politik in
talkshows und nachts bei twitter
verkündet wird das ist nicht richtig so
und schon morgen droht lauterbach im
bundestag die nächste pleite sein
herzensprojekt die impfpflicht könnte
hierdurch fallen weil sich keine
mehrheit für die impfpflicht für alle
abzeichnete wurde hektisch ein
kompromiss gefunden der einzige
gesetzentwurf sieht nun den nachweis ab
oktober für alle ab 60 vor mit
beratungspflicht und dem aufbau eines
imf registers die impfpflicht für alle
ab 18 könnte im herbst folgen ich gehe
davon aus dass wir die impfpflicht
morgen beschließen werden der
kompromissvorschlag der sich in den
letzten tagen hier entwickelt hat ist
aus meiner sicht ein guter vorschlag
doch so sicher ist das nicht die
abstimmung sollte eigentlich zur
gewissensentscheidung werden aber die
unionsfraktionen blockiert schreibt
heute an all ihrer abgeordneten einen
brief darin heißt es nehmen sie an allen
abstimmungen teil stimmen sie unserem
antrag zu lehnen sie die übrigen
vorlagen ab für die fdp ein klarer fall
von fraktionszwang hier wird klar
festgelegt so müsst ihr euch entscheiden
und nicht anders sonst folgt hier nicht
der fraktionsdisziplin und ich sage es
hier das hier leider etwas verpasst
wurde was eigentlich gut wäre für unsere
parlamentarische demokratie eine offene
debatte über parteigrenzen hinweg und
karl lauterbach könnt ihr morgen abend
noch ein problem mehr haben
und hier ist der
bundesgesundheitsminister guten abend
karl lauterbach guten abend herr sievers
einiges an fragen bleibt noch eher
lauterbach warum gestern abend die rolle
rückwärts einen tag nachdem sie etwas
gemeinsam beschlossen haben mit den 16
gesundheitsministern der länder das was
jetzt als begründung dafür anführen dass
ist ja nicht neu das haben sie auch
vorgestern schon gewusst oder zumindest
hätten es wissen können naja die
reaktionen in der bevölkerung hat mir
gezeigt dass die regel hier falsch wirkt
die menschen hätten das signal vernommen
dass es hier eine lockerung ist die wir
beschließen oder dass es darum geht das
gar nicht mehr so gefährlich ist dass
wir in eine andere form von umgang mit
kroner kommen und das wäre das falsche
signal gewesen außerdem war die regelung
nicht wirklich sicher für die
bevölkerung von daher eine uns regel
abzuräumen ist die aufgabe des
gesundheitsministers auch dann wenn sie
im konsens mit den ländern beschlossen
wurde vor zwei tagen haben sich alex
noch gesagt die regelung funktioniert
zwar die jetzige ist aber dauerhaft
nicht notwendig und deswegen können wir
sie abschaffen und ändern was sie jetzt
natürlich erreicht haben herr lauterbach
ist einiges an konfusion auch in der
bevölkerung sie haben gestern abend
gesagt das werd ich wieder einkassieren
jetzt ist das ja eine einschneidende
regel die potenziell jede und jeden in
deutschland betreffen könnte das wort
einkassieren das könnte jetzt ein
bisschen nach gutsherrenart nach dem
motto ich überleg mir heute war's und
morgen kassiers dann einfach wieder ein
schafft denn sowas vertrauen der begriff
ist hier vielleicht nicht optimal aber
es geht doch um folgendes zum schluss
müssen wir regeln haben die
funktionieren diese regelung hätte dazu
geführt dass es möglich gewesen wäre
dass infizierte ohne die quarantäne
regel zu beachten oder isolations regel
zu beachten zum beispiel weiter zur
arbeit gegangen werden und das ist dann
keine gute regel und wir haben das
gemacht um die gesundheitsämter zu
entlasten aber es ist einfach nicht wert
dass gibt das falsche signal
daher muss man dann auch in der lage
sein das wieder wegzunehmen und das
versteht ja auch jeder es bleibt jetzt
dabei derjenige der infiziert ist der
muss in isolation okay das ist keine
gute regel sagen sie das versteht jetzt
jeder sie haben den vorschlag zurück
genommen gestern abend beim kollegen
markus lanz hier im zdf das zeigt
natürlich zum einen ist es immer
spannend dessen talkshow zu gucken auf
der anderen seite stellt sich aber ein
bisschen die frage warum gibt es
überhaupt treffen fachtreffen von
experten ministerinnen ministern wenn
sie dann hinterher einfach mal im
fernsehen ihre meinung ändern ich habe
meine meinung nicht im fernsehen
geändert sondern ich hatte tatsächlich
schon also am nachmittag also als sie
als ich meine eigene position verändert
hatte ich das schon also
in den politisch relevanten gremien hat
sich das schon mitgeteilt ich hatte das
zum beispiel also auch den
fraktionsvorsitzenden raus mützenich
mitgeteilt oder auch
kabinettsmitgliedern ich hätte es heute
morgen ja das habe ich auch gestern
abend angekündigt also ich hätte es
heute sowieso breiter erläutert und
verteidigt aber wenn ich abends in einer
talkshow genau zu dem thema gefragt
werde da kann ich doch nicht
verschweigen was ich am nächsten tag
öffentlich verkünden werde und zwar hat
der super dass ich an dem abend in der
talkshow war nach langer zeit mal bei
markus lanz hat genau
verständlicherweise danach gefragt und
da muss ich doch war da muss ich doch
wahrhaftig und ehrliche antworten
verlangt aber lassen sie uns noch
inhaltlich auf jeden fall über diese in
neue alte regel jetzt reden wer sich
krank fühlt bleibt zu hause geht zum
arzt das ist ja so wenn man in groben
zügen das umschreiben möchte das prinzip
der eigenverantwortung das ja jetzt auch
in deutschland gelten soll diese pflicht
zur isolation die haben auch andere
länder aufgehoben spanien england
schweden norwegen warum trauen sie denn
der eigenen bevölkerung nicht auch über
den weg das hat ja nichts mit misstrauen
zu tun sondern es kommt da waren wie
vorsichtig man sein will in der
bekämpfung der pandemie wir müssen
besonders vorsichtig sein weil wir einen
hohen anteil älterer menschen haben wir
haben einen hohen anteil ungeimpfter
menschen und wir haben auch bisher immer
vorsichtig das ganze gehandhabt das ist
auch der grund weshalb wir im vergleich
zu vielen der länder die sie genannt
haben eine niedrigere sterblichkeit
haben das ist immer der kurs für den ich
auch persönlich stand ich habe immer
versucht die regeln so zu gestalten dass
wir möglichst wenige sterbefälle haben
ohne dass wir die freiheit der
bevölkerung zu stark einschneiden und
die den kurs will ich weiter verfolgen
und dazu hätte die regel hier nicht
gepasst lassen sie uns heute noch
schnell bitte über die impfpflicht reden
auch wichtiges thema im parlament jetzt
morgen sie wollten erst keine
impfpflicht haben sie kategorisch
ausgeschlossen
dann haben sie gesagt auch eine ab 18 da
stehe ich jetzt voll dahinter jetzt
kommt wenn überhaupt eine impfpflicht ab
60 und auch da soll im sommer noch mal
nachgeguckt werden ob sie überhaupt
nötig ist die kriterien sind übrigens
noch relativ unklar warum sagen sie bei
dem ganzen thema nicht gleich die
impfpflicht ist gescheitert die pflicht
ist nicht gescheitert
habe und hoffe dass wir morgen die
impfpflicht
beschließen werden ich gehe sehr davon
aus ich glaube dass die sommer
vernünftigen im parlament sich da
durchsetzen werden und ich werde auch
noch mal sagen die meinung dass sich
verändert wenn die wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse sich verändern sondern muss
auch die meinung sich verändern am
anfang hatten wir varianten die waren
noch nicht so ansteckend wie jetzt da
wäre man möglicherweise mit isolation
und container ohne eine endlich
durchgekommen aber das ist ja keine
aktuelle position von mir sondern ich
bin stabil sagt wir diese besonderen
varianten haben diese gefährlich sind
immer vernehmlich gewesen ich sage auch
dass die impfpflicht ab 18 besser
gewesen wäre also an endlich ab 60 aber
die eigentlich ab 60 die wir
wahrscheinlich morgen beschließen sie
ist ja auch nur eine erste stufe damit
schützen wir 90 prozent derjenigen die
wir mit leben
geschützt hätten und die pflicht ab 18
kann auch noch kennenlernen bis zum
herbst nicht die impfbereitschaft
gestiegen ist sagte der
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch ich danke ihnen und
das gespräch haben wir vor einer stunde
aus termingründen aufgezeichnet
liebe deine ukraine liebe sie in
grausamen zeiten und in den letzten
schwierigen momenten der vers steht auf
dem sockel eines denkmals des
ukrainischen nationaldichters terrace
schewtschenko auf dem zentralen platz
von borodjanka einer kleinstadt 40
kilometer nordwestlich von kiew die
büste des dichters hat einschusslöcher
aber sie steht noch drum herum
allerdings sieht es so aus borodjanka
ist völlig verwüstet manche häuser sind
komplett verschwunden in anderen klaffen
löcher nichts ist mehr dort wo es
hingehört borodjanka einwohner haben ihr
zuhause verloren und sie haben
schreckliches zu berichten
katrin eigendorf war heute dort kathrin
guten abend was hast du von den menschen
dort gehört
ja guten abend christian wir waren in
barra die anker und hatten da
gelegenheit mit den einwohnern zu
sprechen das war wieder eine geführte
tour die veranstaltet wurde vom
ukrainischen ministerium die uns dorthin
gebracht haben und ähnlich wie auch in
butter haben die menschen uns da von den
gräueltaten der russischen soldaten
berichtet sie haben uns erzählt dass die
soldaten mit ihren panzern durch die
straßen gefahren sind dass sie auf die
häuser gefeuert haben eine frau hat mir
berichtet dass ein soldat auf sie
zugekommen ist und ihr mann eine ein
gewehr an den kopf gehalten hat und
gefordert hat das auto zu geben sie hat
es dann in tränen ausgebrochen hat ihn
angefleht ihren mann leben zu lassen
eine andere frau hat uns berichtet wie
der sohn einer freundin auf offener
straße hingerichtet wurde von russischen
soldaten das sind die geschichten die
die menschen uns dort erzählen das
ausmaß der zerstörung was wir dort
erlebt haben ist um vieles größer als
das was wir in butter gesehen haben aber
es ist natürlich noch einmal eine
zusätzliche bestätigung dass butscher
kein einzelfall ist
schreckliche erzählungen die man da hört
jetzt gibt es heute noch meldungen über
viele vermisste nach wie vor im großraum
kiew und es gibt auch dort offenbar noch
orte in denen überhaupt noch niemand war
in dem es noch keinen zugang gegeben hat
kathrin heißt das dort dieselben
schrecklichen entdeckungen befürchtet
werden
damit muss man rechnen was wir heute
erlebt haben ist auch eine gewisse
überforderung
der ukrainischen regierung denn und auch
der lokalen behörden wir haben dort
erlebt wie helfer mit bloßen händen
versucht haben leichen aus den häusern
zu bergen weil nicht das nötige gerät
vorhanden war wir haben dort menschen
erlebt die zwischen den trümmern
herumgeirrt sind völlig traumatisiert
auch gar nicht wussten wohin und was
jetzt mit ihrem leben geschehen soll
niemand hat die lage da im griff und es
gibt wirklich noch orte wo
wo die helfer noch gar nicht hin
vordringen konnten also ich glaube
unser wird nicht die einzige nicht der
einzige ort seien aus dem diese grauen
berichtet werden sondern der gesamte
ring in kiew der ja von
den russischen streitkräften besetzt war
wird wahrscheinlich ein ähnliches ausmaß
uns zeigen an gräueltaten eine reportage
über orte an denen sich die ganze
grausamkeit des krieges zeigt eine
reportage von dir kathrin gleich im
auslandsjournal herzlichen dank für den
moment und sie können den menschen in
der ukraine und auf der flucht natürlich
helfen hier nochmal die kontodaten
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch im internet oder im zdf text
klar dass es heute viele fragen gab im
bundestag an den bundeskanzler und klar
dass sie sich vor allem um den krieg in
der ukraine drehen tut deutschland genug
gegen russland führt die ukraine das war
die große überschrift waffen sanktionen
energie thomas reichert gibt einen
überblick
draußen stellen demonstranten die
schrecken von butscher nach drinnen hat
kanzler scholz in großen buchstaben
etwas aufgeschrieben das gewohnt klingt
dabei einen einschnitt bedeutet
es muss unser ziel bleiben dass russland
diesen krieg nicht gewinnt das ist das
was hinter den aktivitäten steht die wir
unternehmen wenn es nun um waffen die
führung geht wenn es um finanzielle und
humanitäre unterstützung geht wenn es um
die aufnahme der flüchtlinge geht oder
um die sanktions pakete die wir globale
und weltweit vereinbaren aber der stress
land schien es als hoffe stolz auf ein
einlenken russlands auf eine
gesichtswahrende lösung für putin das
ziel aber putin darf nicht gewinnen das
ist neu die wende kommt nach bitterer
kritik aus der ukraine
deutschland helfe zu wenig und zu
langsam
die meisten militärhilfe kommt bislang
aus den usa gesamt wird über 1,4
milliarden euro aber auch das kleine
estland hat mit 222 millionen mehr
geliefert aus deutschland mit 186
millionen ich glaube dass es mit dem
politischen mit dem fehlenden
politischen willen zusammenhängt
insgesamt muss ich leider sagen gibt es
bei der bundesregierung etwas das ich
bewusster halbherzigkeit nenne und die
mit der muss schluss sein wie vor ein
paar tagen hat die bundesregierung alte
ddr schützenpanzers tschechien
freigegeben für die ukraine über die
lieferung weiterer schwerer waffen wir
die verteidigungsministerin aber nicht
sprechen das ist kein keine
bürokratische hürde in diesem
zusammenhang ist eines ganz wichtig die
nato und deutschland darf nicht
riskieren selbst zur kriegspartei zu
werden die sorge vor den kriegsfolgen
führt deutschland das projekt auch die
frage der sanktionen gegen putin die nun
ein bisschen verschärft werden sollen
dazu gehören einfuhrverbote für kohle
dazu gehören transaktions verbote gegen
wichtige weitere russische banken ein
weiteres einfrieren von vermögenswerten
das ist jetzt ein winziger schritt kohle
macht nur vier prozent der russischen
energielieferungen nach europa aus wenn
wir die russische kriegswirtschaft
empfindlich treffen und im regime die
finanziellen ressourcen für den krieg
entziehen wollen dann müssen wir auch
weitergehen in richtung öl und gas
embargo das massaker von botschafter
ändert etwas in berlin das ziel putin
darf nicht gewinnen bedeutet die ukraine
muss gewinnen das wird folgen haben beim
neuen waffenlieferungen und sanktionen
und dann die europäische union mit einem
mittlerweile fünften sanktionspaket
guten anne gellinek da sollen jetzt zum
ersten mal auch energie lieferungen
betroffen seien nicht gas nicht öl
sondern kohle die große frage ist ab
wann
man muss sich das so vorstellen dass die
eu kommission dieses fünfte
sanktionspaket eigentlich schon
ausgehandelt hatte als die schrecklichen
bilder aus butter bekannt wurden und da
hatte man das gefühl das was wir bis
jetzt vorschlagen reicht nicht aus und
so kam ein etwas heiliges kohle embargo
in den vorschlag die eu-mitgliedstaaten
hatten heute zum ersten mal die
gelegenheit sich diesen vorschlag
überhaupt anzusehen und deutschland und
österreich haben sofort eine
dreimonatige übergangsfrist in diesen
vorschlag hineinverhandelt das heißt
drei monate lang noch dürfen laufende
verträge bedient werden in der zeit kann
man sich nach ersatz umsehen das klingt
jetzt sowie eine sanktion mit
verzögerung aber sie ist doch politisch
enorm wichtig weil sie sendet einmal die
botschaft an putin pass auf wir gehen
auch an die energielieferungen heran und
sie sendet eine botschaft auch innerhalb
der eu und sagt es gibt keine
denkverbote mehr seid ja auch ein öl
embargo muss möglich sein und es gibt
viele mitgliedstaaten die glauben dass
die abwehrhaltung deutschlands
österreichs und ungarns nicht mehr lange
aufrecht zu erhalten sein wird
interessant politisch auf jeden fall ein
zeichen finanziell nicht ganz so 4
milliarden von 100 milliarden einnahmen
würden für russland wegfallen bei der
kohle was ist an diesem fünften
sanktionspaket dann wirklich
durchschlagend
es gibt ein paar herausragende signale
würde ich sagen das eine ist zum
beispiel dass die beiden erwachsenen
töchter von wladimir putin auf der
sanktionsliste stehen dahinter steht die
vermutung dass natürlich wladimir putin
sein geld nicht in eigenem namen anlegt
sondern eben es verteilt auf familie und
freunde einer der freunde ist auch der
oligarch oleg deripaska der mit
aluminium reich geworden ist und jetzt
waffenfabriken besitzt und putins krieg
geliefert und das zweite signal ist die
einschränkung des schiffsverkehrs und
des lastwagenverkehrs damit wollen die
europäer den der russischen regierung
zeigen dass es eben keine schlupflöcher
gibt sondern dass man ernst macht damit
schiffsladungen und waren zu überprüfen
und eben keine schiffe mehr in
europäische hafen einlaufen zu lassen
morgen früh setzten sich die 27
vertreter der mitgliedstaaten noch mal
zusammen und man geht davon aus dass das
sanktionspaket dann durchgewinkt wird
unsere europa korrespondentin anna
herzlichen dank nach straßburg und mehr
zum thema in der übersicht die hat hanna
ja unter christian blicken wir
zuallererst auf das treffen der
nato-außenminister rinnen und minister
in brüssel
dabei geht es um weitere
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine und um
die frage ob diese auch schwere waffen
umfassen sollten die sich zum angriff
eignen ein weiteres thema ist die
erhöhung der militärpräsenz in den
östlichen bündnisstaaten zum auftakt
waren
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg dass
der russische angriffskrieg noch monate
oder sogar jahre dauern könne es gebe
einen dringenden bedarf an weiteren
waffenlieferungen
jahre lang wurde diskutiert nun soll die
bundeswehr erstmals mit bewaffneten
drohnen ausgestattet werden zum besseren
schutz der soldatinnen und soldaten
der verteidigungsausschuss des
bundestags stimmte der anschaffung von
insgesamt 140 kampfdrohnen des
israelischen modells heron tp zu die
kampfdrohnen dürfen allerdings nur dann
eingesetzt werden wenn dies explizit im
bundestagsmandat für den jeweiligen
auslandseinsatz vorgesehen ist
nach bundesweiten razzien gegen neonazis
hat innenministerin feser von einem
harten schlag gegen die
rechtsextremistische und
rechtsterroristische szene gesprochen
mehr als 800 polizeibeamte durchsuchten
61 objekte in elf bundesländern die
aktion richtete sich gegen mehrere
militanten neonazi netzwerke vier männer
wurden festgenommen insgesamt ermittelt
die bundesanwaltschaft gegen 50
mutmaßliche rechtsextremisten
schüler auszubildende und studierende
die bafög empfangen sollen ab dem
wintersemester mehr geld bekommen das
hat das bundeskabinett beschlossen die
ausbildungsförderung für studierende
soll beispielsweise um fünf prozent
steigen außerdem will die
bundesregierung die zahl der bafög
empfänger erhöhen deshalb sollen
verschiedene freibeträge angehoben
werden der für das eigene vermögen soll
zum beispiel auf 45.000 euro steigen nun
müssen bundestag und bundesrat über den
gesetzentwurf entscheiden
in israel hat die regierung von
ministerpräsident berisha klappe
mehrheit im parlament verloren eine
abgeordnete der regierungspartei jamina
hat die koalition verlassen angeblich
wegen eines streits über
speisevorschriften während des
bevorstehenden pessach fest da nun weder
das regierungsbündnis noch die
opposition um den früheren
ministerpräsidenten netanjahu eine
mehrheit haben könnte es zu neuwahlen
kommen israel hat in den vergangenen
zwei jahren bereits vier mal ein
parlament gewählt
ein oster paket hatte energie und
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck uns
schon angekündigt da war er gerade mit
einer ersten bestandsaufnahme durch und
hatte festgestellt deutschland dümpelt
dahin beim ausbau erneuerbarer energien
mit dümpeln soll jetzt schluss sein ob
die regierung ihr ziel schafft in den
nächsten 13 jahren praktisch komplett
umzusteigen auf sonne wind und co ist
alles andere als ausgemacht wie sie das
schaffen will hat sie heute dargelegt
auf hunderten seiten es ist das oster
paket und es hat jetzt neue
dringlichkeit bekommen weil die wende in
der energiepolitik nicht mehr nur eine
frage des klimas ist sondern auch der
nationalen sicherheit karl hinterleitner
harry neumann ist wütend hier im
westerwald engagiert sich der aktivist
seit jahren für den naturschutz im
prinzip ist er für erneuerbare energien
aber die artenschutz regeln zu lockern
und seinen wald mit immer neuen
windrädern voll zu stellen das findet
ihr den falschen weg
wir brauchen natürlich ein schlüssiges
konzept für eine energiewende die wir
natürlich brauchen aber das kann nicht
so sein dass die energiewende oder auch
der klimaschutz auf kosten des natur und
des artenschutzes und vor allen dingen
auf kosten des
biodiversitätsschutz es stattfindet denn
im sogenannten oster paket spielt
artenschutz keine große rolle es geht um
eigenständige energieversorgung es geht
um unabhängigkeit von russland und es
geht in zeiten des krieges immer auch um
sicherheit im mittelpunkt dieses paketes
steht eine formulierung die in zukunft
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien vor
allem und gewinnt deutlich erleichtern
und beschleunigen wird und es ist die
formulierung dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien im überragenden
öffentlichen interesse sind und dem
sicherheitsinteresse und damit der
sicherheitspolitik deutschlands dienen
die ziele des pakets bis 20.30 soll 80
prozent des stroms aus erneuerbaren
kommen bis 2035 fast 100 prozent
außerdem sollen sich auf zwei prozent
der landesfläche windräder drehen der
teufel steckt dabei wie immer im detail
sprich bei der umsetzung vor ort am ende
wird es darauf ankommen dass die länder
und die kommunen vor ort die flächen
finden die am besten geeignet sind für
erneuerbare energie und wenn diese
flächen nicht gefunden werden weil sich
länder nicht auf ziele einigen können
weil einige länder weiter an künstlich
erhöhten abstands werten zum beispiel zu
windkraft festhalten dann wird es nicht
gelingen das ziel top bayern hier gilt
die zehnfache höher eines windrades
markiert die entfernung zum nächsten
wohngebiet flächendeckender ausbau bezug
verhindert die bayerische politik bild
das bis auf ausnahmen auch nicht ändern
und kritisiert das poster paket
entsprechend es wird einseitig auf den
wind gesetzt und es wird auch zu wenig
für sonne getan das heißt es bleibt an
vielen stellen auf halber strecke stehen
wirtschaftsexperten sehen das oster
paket positiv ist weiter für die zukunft
in die richtige richtung es ist eine
große wirtschaftliche chance wenn es uns
wirklich gelingt die erneuerbaren
energien auszubauen
gerade die windenergie hat viele
arbeitsplätze verloren auch die
solarenergie diese wird man wiederholen
können wenn auch unternehmen sich wieder
ansiedeln und gleichzeitig machen wir
uns unabhängiger von fossilen
energieimporten die im moment wahnsinnig
teuer sind also das kann wirtschaftlich
nur vorteilhaft sein und so werden wie
im westerwald wohl in ganz deutschland
bald neue windräder aufgestellt für
datenschützer wie harry neumann ist das
ein hoher preis der deutschen
energiewende
anlass für viele fragen an
energieminister haben nachher von meinem
kollegen wulf schmiese im heute-journal
update aber erst mal hier bei uns hanna
die noch mal zurückkommt auf die
wirtschaftliche lage und jetzt auf
russland der kreml hat heute erstmals
seine staatsschulden nicht den us-dollar
sondern in rubel beglichen insgesamt
ging es um knapp 650 millionen dollar
oder schließt sich die frage an ob
russland einem zahlungsausfall immer
näher rückt valerie haller an der
frankfurter börse wie genau aus dieser
schritt heute einzuschätzen die russen
haben immer mehr probleme ihre schulden
mit dollar und euro zu begleichen klares
ist eine folge der sanktionen
die russische zentralbank die dazu
eigentlich in der lage wäre dies ja seit
wochen vom westen kaltgestellt jetzt
haben die amerikaner die daumenschrauben
noch mal angezogen russische
regierungsgelder auf amerikanischen
konnten sind quasi eingefroren die dort
gebunkerten dollar damit nicht mehr
verfügbar also einfach die schulden mit
rubel bezahlen er nicht der haken daran
ist die gläubiger akzeptieren die rubel
vermutlich nicht jetzt hat russland eine
frist von 30 tagen doch noch dollar zu
rückten rauszurücken wenn das nicht
passiert ist das land technisch gleitet
technisch weil geld theoretisch genug da
aber eben wegen der sanktionen nicht
verfügbar ist sinn der sache der kreml
soll sich entscheiden wofür die noch
verbliebenen wertvollen dollarreserven
ausgibt für den schuldendienst oder für
andere zwecke wie zum beispiel die
finanzierung des krieges was würde denn
ein staatsbankrott russlands für den
rest der welt bedeuten an den
finanzmärkten ist der zahlungsausfall
sozusagen schon einkalkuliert das
finanzielle risiko scheint aber ohnehin
überschaubar zu sein weil es relativ
wenige internationale verflechtungen
gibt viele banken haben ihr
russland-engagement seit der krise
ohnehin schon heruntergefahren eine neue
finanzkrise ausgelöst durch russland
damit rechnet hier keiner danke valerie
nach frankfurt
eine meldung vom fußball in der
bundesliga hat augsburg im nachholspiel
des 26 spieltages gegen mainz mit 2 zu 1
gewonnen die partie hätte ursprüngliche
mitte märz ausgetragen werden sollen
aufgrund von zahlreichen corona fällen
bei den mainzern war sie verlegt worden
es gibt eine amtliche unwetterwarnung
des deutschen wetterdienstes vor
orkanartigen böen für den westen die
mitte und den süden deutschlands mehr
dazu später in den wetteraussichten wird
noch der blick auf die lottozahlen sie
lauten 2 19 22 24
29 31 und die superzahl 6 alle angaben
wie immer ohne gewähr
und da wird sagt das gesamte
heute-journal team danke für ihr
interesse wir wünschen ihnen jetzt noch
einen schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend sturmtief nassim hat
inzwischen bereits schottland erreicht
es bringt uns viel regen und viel wind
und es zieht morgen über dänemark weiter
in richtung südschweden diesen kräftigen
regen den merken wir schon heute nacht
denn er überdeckt schon fast ganz
deutschland nur ganz im osten bleibt es
noch trocken
das wird eine wilde nacht mit
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 10 und 5
grad und morgen ist es ähnlich
temperiert wie heute uns erwarten
höchstwerte zwischen 8 und 17 grad und
dazu fällt sehr viel regen im nordwesten
gibt es dazu auch kräftige gewitter und
kräftige schauer dazu pfeift dieser
starker bis stürmischer südwestwind
höhepunkt des windes ist wohl morgen
mittag und dann erwarten uns schwere
sturmböen zum beispiel im thüringer wald
oder im harz orkanartige sturmböen oder
orkanböen beschränken sich aber wohl auf
die nordsee und die bouquets und kaum
ist dieses strom tiefer singen dann nach
osten abgezogen kommt zum freitag schon
gleich das nächste tief hinterher ortrud
das bringt nicht so viel wind aber dafür
viel regen mit und dann kann es in der
nacht auf samstag in den mittelgebirgen
auch schon wieder schneien insgesamt
können so 60 liter regen pro
quadratmeter hier im südwesten
zusammenkommen und in der nacht zu
samstag geht der regen in den
mittelgebirgen in schnee über der
samstag wird deutlich kälter der sonntag
dann schon wieder freundlicher guten
abend